le gouvernement britannique redoute de
nouveaux attentats spectaculaires de la
part de la mouvance islamiste d'oussama
ben laden
côté enquête le fbi et les policiers
anglais continuent leurs investigations
deux nouveaux suspects qui auraient été
en liaison directe avec les 19 kamikazes
viennent d'être arrêtés emmanuel gagné
les dix neuf kamikazes qui ont endeuillé
l'amérique le 11 septembre ont tous
aujourd'hui un visage des photos
d'identité que le fbi a réparti sur
quatre tableaux correspondant aux quatre
commandos en révélant ces photos le
patron du fbi elle espère faire avancer
l'enquêté mais reste prudent sur
l'identité réelle de chaque terroriste
ce que nous avons à faire maintenant
c'est déterminer de quel pays venaient
ces individus et savoir s'il s'agit de
leur vrai nom s'ils ont pris un nom
d'emprunt pour empêcher leur
identification aux états unis dans le
même temps le fbi a confirmé la première
arrestation en lien direct avec les
attentes à celle de mohamed abdi
présenté comme un témoin essentiel
son prénom et son numéro de téléphone
aurait été découvert sur une carte
dans cette voiture une toyota blanche
retrouvée à l'aéroport de dulles
le véhicule aurait appartenu à ce
terroriste
l'avocat de mohamed abdi rejette toute
implication de son client dans la
préparation des attentats mais ne donne
aucune explication
je n'ai rien à vous expliquer pour
l'instant personne ne semble savoir il
n'y a probablement rien dans le dossier
en grande bretagne un autre homme
intéresse beaucoup les big eyes
il s'agit de lofti raissi 27 ans arrêté
la semaine dernière dans cette maison ce
pilote algérien est suspecté d'avoir
formé quatre des kamikazes soupçons
infondés selon son avocat mon client
dément catégoriquement toute implication
dans la récente tragédie et il est
persuadé qu'il sera lavé mais le fbi
peut entendre lotfi raïssi les
etats-unis ont demandé son extradition
aujourd'hui